the relationship you're talking about
here in the public markets there's at
times thousands of people who hold this
stuff and this is could be for companies
or even the MTA was saying that you know
ridership of the subways down 90 percent
and they're worried they don't have the
revenue to pay their bonds and things
like that so that's a very different
type of relationship and also kind of
lender than if you look into private
markets in the private markets is it
safe to say that in almost all of these
relationships are talking about one
single borrower being a company or
corporation and then there's just one
lender per relationship and maybe a
company has multiple lenders but really
it's kind of a one-to-one you're not
seeing any sort of like hey I play from
an SPD and I've got to deal with all the
shareholders on the other side the SPD
it depends and so it's a whole spectrum
I mean in this simplest sense there
might be a borrower and there's a lender
and there's only one lender in the whole
deal and the borrower has a direct
relationship and if the borrower has a
really good relationship with that
lender they may say look we've been
working together for 10 to 15 years you
don't want to blow up I don't want to
blow up if you force me to do all the
things that are in the covenant packages
of this loan I'm gonna default and you
know if you're fun you don't want your
borrowers to default you kind of look
dumb or it might be a lender who that's
the whole reason they do this they're
hoping you default because if you
default they get to own equity in your
business and so knowing who your lender
is and what your lenders sort of goal
was is pretty important you know and
then and then next is also understand
the situation your lender is in so if
your lender is exposed to a ton of [ __ ]
stuff that's like sort of hitting the
fan that's not so good because they
might be acting reaction in a
reactionary way or if stuff's hitting
the fan you may be the least of their
problems and they just don't want one
more to fall it's really hard to kind of
figure that out the other thing is is
your lender levered right so if your
lender gave you money and it gave you
100 million dollars but only 20 million
was theirs and they have a bank gave
them 80 million you know in many ways
leverage is not good because it
magnifies losses
another reason leverage isn't good is
you're not the boss of yourself like you
know usually when we do a deal we're
senior lenders part of the reason we do
that
because you know we don't want to take
more risk than we need to take and the
other part is like let's imagine I have
a portfolio company it has an issue I
almost always know more about what's
going on with that company then some
bank who might be lending to me where
they got like my investment committee
memo in my gaiter room and all this
stuff they don't know the actual
situation on the ground they're not in
the phone with the company every day and
and not having leverage gives you like
sort of the ability to sort of do what
you need to do to make the right
decision rather than doing what you need
to do within the confines of rules that
were set free kovat or pretty
circumstance you could have never exist
expected before there's another
situation where you might have multiple
lenders and those lenders are all acting
differently and I'm trying to figure out
how to navigate what makes sense for one
lender versus another you know one of
the things that's often in terms where
if you have multiple lenders is all
lenders need to be treated pair pursue
or get most favored nation well you
don't want to be as a lender to a
company where the other lender is
getting treated more fairly that might
be a situation where you have one lender
who's being a total jerk your other two
lenders or four lenders or even 5/10
whatever are being great and you have to
figure how to navigate all those
relationships that one lender doesn't
love everything else but then on the
other hand you might be totally thrilled
that you've diversified your capital
base which is something that you often
hear and so and the last part is
understanding like if your private
equity owned you know Blackstone is sort
of a big deal if they go tell their
lender hey I believe that if you give me
a little bit of flexibility here I'm
gonna work this out one they're a really
important client to the lender and the
lender doesn't want to screw that up too
they have a lot of credibility because
they've been through this before if
you're like a ring key being private
equity firm that you know doesn't have
that same sort of relationship with
large banks you can't have those same
conversations so it's really really hard
to say this is how a lender borrower
relationship works because there's so
many other factors involved with what
can people do right now to ruin their
relationship right or reputation
so like we hear all the time hey you
could build your reputation over years
and years and years and you can be the
greatest person in the world in the
markets when the bear market hits it's
really easy to blow up that reputation
that you've built by just doing kind of
shitty things mm-hmm from your
perspective like what are the things
that are most likely for somebody to do
that then leads to kind of the hurt on
the reputation side is it just not only
do what they're supposed to do or
something more complex so you know so
usually when something goes wrong it's
the borrower's fault
right they didn't do something they were
supposed to do in this case like a virus
occurred everyone got sick so everyone
had to stay home and so people stopped
spending money and like it's sort of not
your fault anymore and one reaction
might be to go to all your lenders and
say everything's fine everything is not
fine like I loved my apartment four
times this week like [ __ ] you if you
think everything's fine and you know one
way to ruin your reputation or
confidence from your lender is to be
ignorant or
you know one temptation that a lot of
founders and entrepreneurs have is to
show confidence because if you don't
show confidence in the market people
assume things are worse than they are I
don't think this is the time to do that
I think this is the time to say here's
our plan and here's our base case here's
how we think things are gonna affect us
in a good scenario doesn't affect us or
affects us less than we thought in
Abby's case it affects us and here's
what would happen in a bear case this is
how bad it can get I've found in the
conversations I'm having with our
portfolio the more worried the founder
is less worried I am the less worried
the founder is the more worried I am
because it makes me think that someone
has to worry and it's not them the
second thing is hiding information you
know one temptation is to say oh my god
you know I'm lending money to because
because often we're working with
companies they're lending money to other
companies and they may have a loan
that's not performing one thing they may
want to do is refinance that loan and
say well you know this is a borrower
that we've worked with for a long time
you know they're struggling and they
already were struggling and this is a
moment that makes it even harder let's
let's let's lend to them again let's put
a little bit more money out because I'll
help them get through this time you know
in rare cases that's the right thing to
do but I would say look like you
normally it
you're gonna get yelled at for making a
bad loan this is the time that you're
not gonna get yelled at just like cut it
off and even if it was Cogan related
people understand if it wasn't Kovan
related people are gonna still think it
was Cogan related and give you the
benefit the doubt so it's a really good
moment to kind of cut things out from
the book or make if you saw something
trending in a bad way make this the
quarter that you read it off but the way
that you can really screw this up is
lying pretending like you're a more
optimistic than you are committing fraud
or doing things that are gonna put your
lender or your investor in a bad
position with their investors because
those are things that are sort of
unforgivable